hey i'm joe i'm the lead game designer
on four guys ultimate knockout and i
just wanted to reach out and say thank
you to everyone who's been playing and
enjoying their games so far
as a team we've been looking at all the
fan arts the memes and the montages that
people have been posting online
and the response to the game has really
blown us away today we just wanted to
give everyone their first sneak peek of
the rounds and the costumes that they
can be enjoying as part of four guys
season two
in season two you'll be dressing your
full guy as a medieval hero
and competing across brand new rounds
inspired by epic quests from the middle
ages
traverse giant drawbridges dodge
swinging axes and scale movable sea
drams in the quest for ultimate
game show glory
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed the sneak peek of
full guide season two we're still adding
the finished touches to development but
if you want to stay up to date then
pool guys game on twitter is where you
want to be see you on the start line